Yes, yes.
And not only in Russia, but of course in post-Soviet states, yes...
many people speak Russian; not just in Ukraine, but also in Kazakhstan...
and in many other countries Russian is spoken.
And it is one of the major World Languages, alongside Spanish, Arabic etc.
I will tell you, it was about the time...
Yes – it was ten years ago, when I really began focusing on studying Russian.
Unfortunately, I haven’t practiced my Russian in a long time.
When I visited Ukraine twice I was able to hear a little more Russian.
And so, unfortunately,
speaking accurately in Russian requires effort.
And when I don’t study Russian for a prolonged period of time,
of course I’ll forget words and make many mistakes.
But for me that’s unimportant.
I will show people that right now I’m speaking with difficulty,
but it’s still a huge pleasure for me whenever I get the chance to speak Russian.
And it doesn’t hinder our communication at all, I understand you perfectly...
...and think there is no need to be afraid of making mistakes.
(Yes)
They are inevitable, but shouldn’t hinder communication.
Yes, and even if I focus on speaking Russian,
I am afraid – no, I am not afraid,
however I know that I will never speak with zero mistakes, ever.
Never.
When it comes to English... I was in international business for many years,
with people from Sweden, Germany...
And not to mention from Japan.
Well, the Japanese aren’t the best with English,
but Swedes and Germans are great with English,
But nonetheless there will always be some mistakes.
These mistakes will, how do you say... “reflect”... reflect the habits of their native languages.
Of course: here in Canada we have a co-worker from Russia,
no, not Russian, he’s a Russian-speaking Moldovan,
so post-Soviet country.
And his English is great, simply great,
he can express himself perfectly.
He understands everything, and speaks like any regular Canadian,
but articles don’t exist for him.
No, no, there are simply no articles.
And he speaks freely with no articles, and everyone understands him.
...So if I were to focus on Russian right now and study hard,
I would like to learn to speak more accurately,
but even so I know I will never speak with zero mistakes.
And this doesn’t matter, it doesn’t take away the pleasure I find in studying Russian.
Absolutely. It all depends on your goal.
After all, you’re not aiming to work as an interpreter at the United Nations
or become the President’s interpreter.
(Yes)
If that were the case, investing extra effort in speaking flawlessly would be worth it.
I’ve been living in the US for 10 years and have been studying English since age 5,
and I’m sure that I still make many mistakes but people are well-mannered and don’t point them out.
Russians also make many mistakes in their native language.
They wouldn’t confuse a word’s case as a foreigner might,
but word stress, word definitions and so on.
Language is profound and boundless, like, I don't know... an abyss; so there’s no trouble in making mistakes.
Question: If I want to improve my speaking...
...and make less mistakes,
what would you suggest, how could you help me make less mistakes?
My suggestion is this: hire a teacher – someone who can explain your mistakes to you,
or at least, a native speaker who isn’t your spouse or close friend,
because that can cause conflicts,
and ask them to communicate with you regularly, write your mistakes down and then tell you about them.
Then, I think, you will need to direct your attention to these mistakes.
So let’s say you constantly make mistakes with word cases,
since we tend to make the same old mistakes over and over.
You will need to stop and say to yourself: hold it right there, here is where I need to change something.
So, we need awareness and to consciously use our cognitive skills
to slowly train ourselves to stop making a particular mistake.
This is the recipe I’ve come up with. What do you think of it?
Yes... Well, I understand Russian grammar,
I do, I understand everything, have done a lot of reading.
But I cannot speak and simultaneously think consciously about the rules of speech,
so how can I develop speaking reflexively/intuitively?
And what you said is correct, when I’m studying, I don’t know, Arabic or any other language,
I will be speaking to a tutor via the Internet.
And every time the tutor will make a list of my mistakes.
And I will be able to review these conversations... no, just the lists...
What I mean to say is I have a recording of the conversation.
And I see that every week I make the same mistakes.
And every time the tutor will correct me,
but the next lesson I’ll make that same mistake again.
Even though I know the mistake, and I’ve been corrected.
And how do you, how should I say, how do you fix that?
How do you correct that?
Correct, yes.
Well, Steve, I think we shouldn’t forget about awareness and repetition.
Right, you may make the same mistake twice, thrice, a fifth time,
but on the seventh you will stop and say to yourself: “No, something’s wrong”.
So there still needs to be some form of control over what you’re saying.
Actually, I agree with your method too. You say we need to get used to a language,
You say we need to get used to a language, do a lot of listening and reading,
(yes)
so the language begins to feel native and your ear becomes trained to intuitively catch the mistakes you make.
So, there needs to be total combination of a huge amount of listening, reading and constant mindfulness.
As a result we get something that’s natural and effortless for you.
I also think you shouldn’t be afraid,
and to admit ... I admit that I won’t be able to speak without mistakes.
But I also know, like you said, little by little I will gradually develop new habits.
For example, take cases: the instrumental case is the most simple (“s nami”, “s vami”),
..because it's slightly different:
"-i", "-e", "-a" (the endings of the other cases) are complicated,
but “s vami”, “s nami” – those are easy to remember.
And my brain will be able to create phrases with these cases that sound natural.
Over time, the number of these natural-sounding phrases with correct grammatical structure will slowly increase.
Of course, it’s necessary for somebody to correct you
or you yourself should mark the difficulties you encounter.
But there are difficulties still. So don’t...
...don’t get to worked up over it, you know?
Yes, there’s no need to worry too much,
you must to understand what you need to work on.
(To worry)
Someone may not even know they’re making a mistake,
(Yes)
is it “sprosit’ vam” or “sprosit’ vas” (to ask you)?
The correct way is “sprosit’ vas”,
but all my students say “sprosit’ vam”.
If I don’t tell them that’s wrong, they’ll never find out.
So the delight of having a teacher lies in their ability to direct you on what you need to work on,
And that’s about it.
(Yes)
Yes
Okay, well, I hope that next time we speak Russian I will be able to improve slightly.
Your Russian is wonderful, it can only become even better.
Yes, nevertheless, I think your videos and channel are very encouraging, how do you say that?
Thank you, We could say: “motiviruyut” (motivating, encouraging).
Motivating – that’s what's most important.
(Thank you very much)
OK, thank you, thank very much, farewell!
(Thank you, it was a pleasure, farewell!)
Farewell, Goodbye!
It was a pleasure, farewell!
It was a pleasure